in this video we shall go in depth into
the home of kong we will explore monster
vs skull island
it is the name most often used to
describe a fictional island that first
appeared in the 1933 film king kong
and its sequels and remakes and any
other king kong based media
it is the home of king kong and several
other species of creatures
mostly prehistoric and in some cases
species that should have been extinct
long before the rise of mammals and also
monsters that are just fictional
alongside with a primitive
society of humans so let us see how the
ecosystem and life forms of skull island
2017
detail out in landscape climate and how
life here works
location skull island is the main
setting of gong skull island movie
the island is located in the south
pacific and sits in the eye of a massive
swirling storm system that has enabled
its concealment from the outside world
the island is situated atop an entrance
to the hollow earth
while the original skull island of 1933
and the 2005 remake
states that the place is found west of
sumatra which means it is located in the
indian ocean
the most of us version however is
located in the pacific ocean and google
maps has even displayed a location just
for fun it is located around 4 000
kilometers
west of south america and the same
distance southwest of the united states
landscape regarding the island it has a
vague resemblance of a human skull
the island is approximately 82 to 60
kilometers at its greatest extent
under the map with grits and
approximately 60 to 70 of the grid area
within those bounds is water giving us
an approximate landmass of around
1 500 to 2 000 square kilometers or
around the same size as the small island
of mauritius
the island has vast lagoons and
waterways that traverse all through it
in the center there are mountains and
steep hills followed by thick
tropical forests that cover most of the
place with batches
of grasslands and marsh lands as well
climate as the island is situated in the
middle of the ocean and with higher
elevations seen throughout the central
area of the place
heavy intermittent rains are bound to
occur throughout the year
as is normal for islands in the tropical
regions hawaii which is just 3 000
kilometers away and slightly in the
northern hemisphere
along with higher elevations would be a
good example of how the climate of skull
island would be
the temperature range would therefore be
in a 30 degrees or minus
plus or one two degrees centigrade this
kind of climate with good amount of rain
as well as a diverse landscape
and warm temperature coupled with
isolation would most definitely bring
about a strange and lush ecosystem
a vegetation as stated earlier the
island is situated in the tropical
regions of the pacific ocean
with abundant rainfall and warm
temperature as well as a diverse
landscape
therefore an abundance of plant life
would be expected to cover the different
niches
of this ecosystem the planes are seen to
have tall and short grass species
and marshes with semi-aquatic plants
they are also the large bamboo forest in
which the team of 1973
encountered and fought against a giant
spider
named the mother longlegs they are also
lush every green tropical forest
throughout the place
which serve as a habitat for many animal
species of the island
there are also carnivorous plants which
are human sized and can devour small
animals
the herbivores now we come to the
animals of skull island and we will
discuss briefly on each of them
the first of these herbivores seen in
the movie are deers which run away from
the seismic charges dropped from
helicopters
then they are the giant skir buffaloes
which are found in marshes
and which are giant cousins of water
buffaloes and can reach
heights of up to 45 feet in height next
are the mag materials seen in the comics
and these two
are docile creatures which are as big as
the skirba flows
then we also have the reports of water
buffalos and other small herbivorous
creatures
next we have the carnivores on land and
in the dense tropical jungles we have
quite a number of deadly predators that
stock everything that walks
even members of their own species
sometimes these are the death jackals
which are semi-reptilian
mammal creatures kind of like a mix
between wolf and raptors
then we have the elusive holy tigers
which are white in color
and have stacked like antlers they are
ambush predators as well
then there are the ambush predators like
the vine stranglers
the spore mantises and mother long legs
each of them disguise as planned life
and each of them
that are part of a hybrid class of life
form which are
part plan part animal now let's see more
about these ambush predators
the vine stranglers are named for their
vine like appearance and their behavior
of strangling their victims to death
they are arboreal insects that live and
hunt on trees
the mother long legs are gigantic
spider-like creatures that
that stand around five to seven meters
tall they possess incredibly long legs
that resemble bamboo stalks
allowing them to blend in seamlessly
with the surrounding bamboo forest
sporomantis resemble stick insects
elevate one so big
instead it mimics a fallen law we also
find swarm locus which are ambush
predators that lie
upside down in the water and extend
their wood-like claws to the surface
before using them to grasp on
unsuspecting preys the flying creatures
so now we shift from the thick canopy to
the skies and here we have deadly
insects which are all oversized as
compared to the similar species found
across the entire world
an example of this is the giant wasp it
is assumed that is very similar to a
normal wasp but approximately the size
of a human hand
there are also dragonflies and other
flying insects bigger than normal ones
then there are the psycho vultures which
are grey large
bed-like creatures possessing a white
wingspan and a snub-nosed
skull leaf wings which are sub-species
are smaller
and more pterosaur-like creatures that
are about the same size as an adult
human
they are green in color with yellowish
heads orange wings and
long spear-like snouts the aquatic
monsters
from the skies and into the waterways
and lagoons of skull island
we of course have fishes and normal
marine life forms
as they are not hindered by the swirling
storm system just off the coast of skull
island
but in these waters there are monstrous
creatures as well
well of course we saw the maya squid the
cephalopod that battles kong
which later becomes brunch for the king
my squids resemble a colossal's cross
between a squid and an octopus
and are over 100 feet long then there
are the siren jaw which are massive
crocodilian-like creatures covered in
plant life
with small orange eyes and large jaws
filled with razor-sharp teeth
when submerged in water the creature
resembles an island they are also hybrid
creatures that are
part plant part animal next we have the
titans
of course we have the two titan species
of skull island titanoscong
and the skullcrawlers of the cranium
reptons of course most of us know by now
by heart what they are
but just for the new ones if there are
any the 104 feet tall
kong is an ape-like super species that
evolved back in prehistoric times
while the species share common ancestry
with modern day apes
it is considered to be an entirely new
categorization of life on its own
skull crawlers are large reptilian
creatures with only two long full limbs
and no hind limbs
as well as long prehensile serpentine
tails
they also have long and slender yet
muscular sturdy bodies
and are hyper carnivorous and they would
starve to death in a day if they don't
get to eat
or hibernate and then we have another
titan that would emerge on the island
soon enough and that would be camazotz
and this one is a giant bad titan and
where he sits on the food web is yet
unknown now we shift from the titans to
the hollow earth
and we come to the most interesting part
of the island that is the hollow earth
entry points
it is said that the ground beneath the
scala island is filled with enormous
cavities that lead the way
into massive subterranean hollow spaces
which are home to even more deadly
creatures like the
nazuki or warbats which by the new
information we got
are actually a packed species that hunt
other creatures and titans in the hollow
earth cavities
their spines are poisonous and are
medium in size anyway the titans all
over the world are converging towards
the island
and therefore the hollow earth would
sooner or later become unstable
thereby making the island dangerous to
live on which
might be why kong was transported away
in a gvk
teaser us humans as revealed in skull
island the birth of kong
the ewe natives which are humans in
skull island were originally not native
to skull island as their ancestors
migrated to the island thousands of
years ago
they arrived in time to witness gong's
parents towering above
dead skull crawlers even after a lot of
time they did not advance and stuck to
their old ways
due to their primitive lifestyle the ewe
primarily used ancient weapons such as
spears and bows
they also prefer to ambush their enemies
as many painted their skin to blend in
with the stone architecture around the
place
the eb natives live in harmony with the
rest of skull island's creatures
but they fear the skull crawlers the
most so what do you think
is skull island a good place to bring
your wife on your honeymoon
if not then put your thoughts on the
comment section below and if yes
what would you need a pina colada or a
sex on the beach
and so with that we come to the end of
the video about everything in skull
island the ecology and the ecosystem of
this strange place
so like subscribe and smash the
notification bell
for regular updates until the next one
take care fam